lexi lagan is making nevada history this
month when she represents team usa
in three different sharp shooting events
this is so impressive we have john
treats joining us
in studio to tell us more john
absolutely
barry and joe lagan aren't allowed to
watch their daughter lexie compete in
the olympics in person
it's disappointing but they did the hard
part they raised a high character
olympian
it's a special year for a family with
many community firsts and the legends
have another tale to tell
for one of nevada's most storied cities
from the peaceful to the powerful
boulder city is at the soul of southern
nevada
but for the first time in its charming
history
this proud silver state city has a
contender for olympic gold
i'm going to the olympics it's not just
a
not just a pipe dream or just something
down you know a long long road it's
right here i'm right there
she's a sharp shooter with a soft touch
kind but with killer consistency on
average the
the 10 rings about the size of an eraser
head off of a pencil
and in order to be competitive
internationally you need to be hitting
that
eraser head about seven to eight
times out of ten the foundation of this
firearm shooting phenomenon
comes naturally lexi's dad barry is a
25-year metro police officer
and instructor at the range he retires
on her first day of competition a lot of
guys they have sons and
my son plays football my son plays
baseball well my daughter shoots and
that's
that's excellent for me to say not only
does she shoot she's achieved the
highest mark possible by getting to go
to the olympics
as for lexi's family the only ones with
more tenure in town are the bighorn
sheep
granddaddy came here to be one of the
first to be the first hard hat diver on
lake mead
and then my grandfather was with the
bureau of mines and helped
with some of the tunneling and the
history gets richer
one of lexi's relatives was a high
scaler on the hoover dam construction
and her great grandmother gloria is the
oldest living showgirl
she dated howard hughes four generations
later lexi is taking flight to tokyo
now i get to represent it on this world
stage it's something that i'm very proud
of and i just really love my community
lexi lagan boulder city's perfect
pioneer
absolutely and she'll be competing again
in three events and based on her scores
compared to the rest of the contenders
around the world
she has a legit chance to meddle in two
of them she would be the first u.s
shooting medalist in close to
four decades